yeah let's actually start off exactly
where
we
initially began before we started
recording because i feel like that's
such a perfect
entry point
which is
that
you called it a paradigmless
natural state that most recently you
felt
and will you elaborate on that for us
yeah um
up until
august of 2021
i had some sort of like okay i was
enlightened right i considered myself
enlightened and i knew that the self
that i considered enlightened was not
real you know that it's just a thing you
say you're describing this experience by
saying you know i am enlightened this
experience is an enlightened experience
it's expensive it's perceived as
all one
you know pure oneness emptiness
you know nothingness
awareness
so i followed the awareness route to
that realization to enlightenment
basically what i considered
enlightenment at the time which is what
gave me this expansive view and the view
of oneness
because everything was made of awareness
very clearly
um
all people
all things
and i was
one and the same as this awareness i was
both the thing awareness and
the objects of that awareness itself
so i considered okay
that's done to me this is non-duality
you know awareness aware of awareness
so that's where i was
and no self in the sense of no collate
character the collect character had been
completely seen through
all of its thoughts its memories
everything was like oh that's just a
story it was never real
but i started to watch frank gang's
youtube videos and i was like
there's a difference between his
experience and mine mine isn't trippy
it's not
i mean yes i have blissful states right
i have blissful kind of psychedelic
states but it's not anything to write
home about
of course this is spectacular
uh perceiving no separation beautiful
but
there's this thing that my experience
doesn't match everything that he says
and that was the first time i'd
encountered someone's teachings that
i couldn't relate to
so then i started thinking about
what if
what i'm in is a construct nice
now i used different things i started to
think about deep sleep
you know whatever deep sleep is doesn't
matter but it was like my gateway into
thinking
what is this awareness that i think is
my continual baseline
state
am i truly always aware what is my
experience of deep sleep
then i started think about flow
you know when you're in an activity and
you just lose yourself in that activity
after that activity i'm like yeah i was
aware because i can remember so i was
aware there wasn't an absence of
awareness
then i realized that's an afterthought
in the moment when i was in flow i was
not aware
in the literal sense
and so that started to crack this
awareness paradigm
and whether or not you know you're away
or not doesn't even matter you know
whether you're wearing deep sleep away
in flow state doesn't matter that's just
the train that i took to get to you know
this place of oh my goodness what
so
after that
taking into account the fact that i
didn't match frank's experience
i started to think about the nature of
awareness
and i thought what is awareness
without something to be aware of
and that was my main final sort of
inquiry and i know that theoretically
true non-duality is awareness aware of
awareness which is technically one thing
right
but then i started thinking that's like
saying
i'm eating but there's no food right i'm
eating and eating
it doesn't
quite make sense there are two things
here awareness implies
something to be aware of
whether it's awareness aware of itself
or awareness aware of multiplicity
that's still the subtlest of dualities
and so last year
i sat down and i found myself meditating
and i was doing what frank spoke about
in his videos which is vapasana and i
was looking for the source of this
awareness
because for something to be in a subtle
duality it has to be a subject and an
object
a subject must be present perceiving
something
so i realized hey there's this pull in
my head there's a sensation in my head
that believes it is aware bear in mind i
had popped the locality bubble in a way
as well i no longer felt i was in my
head so it was a perfect paradigm ideal
enlightenment
but
this thing was taking credit for
awareness
somehow subtly
and in a moment that i objectified that
thing
it was like
a desolate wasteland immediately
it was like um gravity was acting on the
body for the first time i remember
sinking back into the couch i was
sitting on with this crazy inertia
and because before you know you've got
the center in the body and you feel like
you are sort of holding it together and
then as soon as the center falls out
it's like oh my goodness
the body is being acted on by gravity in
the same way as like this pen or
whatever
so
the center fell away completely
and i realized that awareness
and any other paradigm
god
non-duality
spirituality anything all of that fell
away all of it and that's why i haven't
said anything on social media for six
months this is the first time i say
anything publicly because it took me
this long to be able to understand what
had happened because i can no longer use
any concepts or any words before i could
say oh i've now recognized awareness of
awareness i have now recognized myself
as god consciousness the pure eye but in
that moment all of that fell away
every single thing
and so i simply do not know anymore
you know i did not know
now i don't know i knew i knew you know
you say you don't know but in a way
you've got the safety of knowing like
i'm awareness i'm all powerful infinite
awareness
but you're something
so much bigger actually
you're you are beyond even the the
highest of non-dual paradigms
so that's what happened
and for the last six months there's
sensations in the body and like
wind and sounds are all like doing this
they're overlapping and the body has no
place in the center so the body feels
like it's been as if it were like a
puppet
and then the the strings were cut on the
puppet
or
like i told frank where the body was
normally like the center now the
universe feels like a hand and the
body's like one of the fingers
or the body is like one of the things
floating around in a snow globe it has
no anchor anymore
and since then
true no suffering true no self and true
no suffering no self in god no self in
awareness
no self in any paradigm whatsoever
completely groundless
beautiful
yeah it feels like an honor to be
um
that you felt an energetic draw to be
able to share here with me on this
channel for the first time in in six
months
and
it also
um feels really divine with the way that
um
where we're both at because
i feel very similarly to what you
describe which is the inability to
really speak
about it the last half a year
also
and although
um
there have been
although there have been shifts
happening um
were you
what you just described and how i feel
um
it it um
it's really like destructive of any
paradigms and ideas and concepts
and
i like how you called it the train of
awareness because that is kind of like
what it is is um it's like a train that
we take um back inwards um to source if
you will or to um knowing what we truly
are um
and even that
um exploding into the mystery infinite
mystery
um
and
and then yeah it becomes yeah very
groundless
and also
um
[Music]
the like i i like how
also
shunyata emptiness can be also
translated to
hollowness
that's another great um
yeah like recent um feeling because and
then like the hollowness can sort of
like the intelligent um energy or
infinity if you will can
sort of
um just most
effortlessly just flow the body mind to
where it needs to be um and
even to serve the rest of
creation like waking up
um
and without a sense of self that is
constantly
needing to tie everything to its
worth or
an image
and things like that
yeah you're completely free floating you
know by the will of whatever you want to
call it
you are no longer resisting anything and
so you're following your literal divine
path
you know if you if we were to call it
anything the true freedom of no longer
resisting
some sort of you know given way for the
character
and um
yeah just not not being locked into
anything the the free flow of not being
locked in
is insane you know as long as you're
locked into something whether you know a
hobby
a job
a non-dual paradigm enlightenment
you are limiting yourself
you are setting up boundaries in which
the character can only move like you
know this within this paradigm
and as soon as you shared the paradigm
and you you're a free agent
you'd be surprised you know you just get
done whatever to and with you're just a
puppet for whatever this is
i love how you also described it like a
being the hand and then
of the universe and then the body being
a finger
um that's a great one i've also
used the uh the towel as an analogy
because you know the towel has all of
the
little
little
pokey yeah bits for that are strings
that then
are what like absorbs the water from our
body when we rub it
yeah and so then where
that's the towel
ness if you will is like the
universalness
and then all those little body minds are
the little strings
um
[Music]
and i and
it's just how the mystery expresses
itself in this dimension we could say
yeah
yeah and yeah it's a seeming
multiplicity but not really
you know and it's not even wholeness it
is not even oneness
you know so if you're stuck in oneness
yeah just drop it and see what happens
it is something far beyond that
total
mystery the first time you can say
nothing about something that's that's
such a big deal because we always have
something to say
you know we always we can always talk
about stuff and even this we're talking
about but we you know we can't really
but what a feat to actually be
experiencing something for once that i
cannot describe
yeah
and you know the
it's interesting what you said about the
like mission awakening mission before
i was thinking
you know people are
sort of caught up in different you know
things some people are like spiritual
some people believe in like spreading
the message of awakening and i was like
unknowingly negating those roles i was
thinking you know that's not the point
the point is to
the point is to just get yourself
enlightened and then whatever happens
happens you know so there was like this
kind of bias to like uh you could say
spirituality and like spreading of the
message because what does it matter
because source doesn't care if anyone
wakes up to it
and then when the center fell away i
found myself immensely involved in
spirituality for the first time started
reading the law of one
got into the raw channeling all of the
stuff that i'd previously thought is
ridiculous you know mass awakening um
you know
these goals that i thought were
futile or
egoic
have now just started flourishing
without a center so there's now this
like mission
mission to
help people see what's seen here but
with no internal egoic need to do so
and it seems to truly just be the way
that things are you know it's not
because someone needs to feel fulfilled
by teaching and making someone else
enlightened it's not that it's even when
the center falls away you're still you
still find yourself helping others
whether you like it or not
because that's just the way things go
it's like this thing wants to spread
itself
yeah if if you're not spreading it
you're in a way caught in a bit of a
paradigm i have read um
what's it perfect brilliant stillness by
david cars and he said he's just you
know he woke up
and no matter how many people uh begged
him to teach this thing he just refused
because he doesn't want to lose it he
doesn't want to make it into a concept
you know that's kind of like fear-based
if you let yourself loose completely
you'll find yourself naturally
spreading this thing
so whether
whether it's via spirituality
law of one
dharma missions
you know
it's great it's good and it's the way
this thing moves
this thing moves by spreading itself
it's
it's definitely
i mean it's not entirely true but it's
pretty true to say that
it's the way things should go
it is
the evolution of humankind
toward you know the foreseeable future
so it's great you know what you're doing
with the team and
just getting out there and
having fun while doing it
it's fantastic and before i would have
negated that you know i would have
thought it doesn't matter i don't know
why they care you know why do they care
and here i am caring so much like these
people need to wake up
so yeah you just get you get totally
destroyed everything all you all the
stuff you thought
you know i was like crystals don't work
no
apparently you know everything else
relative truth
i thought the law of one was just
relative but that's the thing the
relative is the absolute there is no
absolute truth the absolute is the
relative they are intertwined and one
and the same
and enlightenment is not a goal it's a
it's the journey it's this entire thing
happening
whether spiritual not spiritual you want
to renounce all your stuff you want to
go live in an ashram you want to i don't
know party it up in the bahamas who
cares
who cares
it's the way this thing moves
yeah
we could even say that there's a
there are a couple different um
thresholds and at um
like these different thresholds of
deconstruction we could say
um of the sense of
let's say four things primarily that
i've noticed it's self
others
world and stories
those four things
and the deconstruction of those through
inquiry vipassana
concentration meditation realization
integration
that
that typically takes us to thresholds
and we could say that if we get locked
into one of those paradigms or
thresholds
that there's typically still a
a
non-deconstructed remnant left because
we're still locked into a conceptual
paradigm
and then as we sort of blow through
those because there's still something
that
feels
unwhole or it still feels
like the seeking impulse is still there
we
we recognize that it becomes more and
more non-conceptual
um
paradigm-less
and
when that fully hollows out
then
it's an organic
feeling
without a sense of self
that
the only thing that's left
is for this
body mind to be a vessel or a channel
for the universe knowing itself and
waking up to itself and there's nothing
else
for it to do for it to be for it to
express
and it's that's that's also
liberation um
like you said earlier there's you're
following the divine blueprint um and
there's just such a
like there's a warmth it's like a
it becomes like a musical instrument
that's
just yeah being played in the symphony
um
yeah exactly
yeah you know like you said if you're
locked into something
no matter how enlighten
your experiences
there's an anchor somewhere that's
keeping you locked in whether that's a
story
or a
sensation
or a self
you know
as long as you have a self in something
you will be locked into something and
that's just that
and it can be
as simple as
like three questions
one are you suffering
yes or no
two
is there a self
is there any self do you identify as
anything
and then third one
is there a subject to your experience
if something is happening to something
else
there is an anchor there is a subtle
self there is a paradigm
because this is subjectless there is no
subject here whatsoever
there is literally no one no one
experiencing
there is no thing experiencing not even
awareness is experiencing because that
makes awareness a subject not even god
is experiencing itself because then god
is a subject
this is completely subjectless you can
say it's pure object but even object has
to exist with reference to a subject so
you know when people come to me it's
like hey are you suffering because they
think they're done are you suffering
uh yeah you know it's uh sometimes they
are kind of uncomfortable moments and
but but the awareness is there and i'm
aware of it and i'm like okay you know
that's that you're you're just you're
stuck you're stuck because you're still
suffering you're just rationalizing
you're saying oh i'm aware of it
you know good or whatever oh oh you're
combating your suffering with like a god
consciousness mentality which is like i
don't need to suffer i am super strong
i'm infinite uh god infinite awareness
still not
still not
and there's a subject there there's
something taking agency what's doing
that
what's doing that what's deciding like
oh i'm taking witness position oh i am
awareness
because when this whole thing is
flattened out and you see that there's
zero subject
the the so-called subject from before is
like happening but it's happening as
like
simultaneous um
like firework events
like when i decide like i wanna watch
netflix or something i can feel the
sensation of wanting to watch netflix a
pull across my chest
which before was like oh i either
subject want to go watch netflix now i
feel the sensation arise the thought of
netflix simultaneously but there's no
one underneath that
and there's there's no there's literally
no agency no subject total emptiness
it's desolate desolate desolate and
another thing that i realized with the
that recent shift
was that this entire thing
perceivably now takes up no space
no space and it that was one of the most
frightening
aspects of this realization because i
knew theoretically okay we're a dream in
god's mind you know we're a thought
we're the original thought but
practically in my experience things kind
of had shape i could see their ephemeral
i could see the transparency of the
awareness that things were made up of
but
it didn't do this you know it didn't
nothing collapsed on itself
and now when i look around even though
there's a parent space in the room i'm
in
i can see that this is not even an
atom's
size of space
we we barely exist
we barely exist and um you can say we
don't we don't exist in a literal sense
none of this is real in the
sense you know of
taking up space and happening in time
it's all just you know in the exact same
way as the dream you have at night very
common analogy that non-deal teachers
use you know in what space did that room
that you dreamt of take place
and
i knew that theoretically and because
i'd heard it but i never saw it
so in that moment when that dropped away
i was like
because the walls just closed in the
body
just disappeared
and now no matter how far i look
it's like smooshed
yeah it just takes up
no volume
which is insane and if that's not your
experience like carry on you know don't
don't people mustn't be discouraged
um because i see so many people making
like rationalizations like i said i'm
aware of it
um i know i'm awareness so it's fine
it's hurting the character but it's not
hurting me all of those are
justifications they're all paradigms
they're all your mind trying to keep you
in this box that you don't see the
reality
that we're talking about
you know very very clever very smart
mind let's use the most subtle non-dual
trap the last one
let's hope they stay here and if they
see through it damn it
but so many don't even teachers
there's so many teachers that at least
perceivably from their teachings are
teaching from a paradigm which i
understand
in one way because if we didn't we'd
have nothing to talk about and we just
sit there like this
but
it's a hint to
really investigate your experience and
be honest
what am i sticking to what do i believe
myself to be do i believe myself to be
god
is that my experience
is life happening to me no matter who
that me is life happening to awareness
life happening to god
if that's the case it should be
investigated
yeah
i love the three
that you brought up it's a really great
way to have an access point or an entry
point
um
so of course suffering is and just being
honest with these two suffering
um
if there is still suffering if there is
still a sense of self
and then how do you differentiate the
second and the third the sense of self
and the subject
i would say that the subject is like a
perceivable thing
and the sense of self is an
identification a meaningful
identification
so the sense of self is like i rest my
sense of self in awareness i know
intellectually
and it's my experience that i am god
i am awareness
and then the third one would be
is experience happening to something
because you see some people stop on the
second and they say no i'm none of these
things i don't have any identifications
because their mind is smart enough
to say no i don't identify as anything
i identify as what is whatever i don't
have any identifications but then
there's still a sense of
separation in the third step
is this
thing that you're not identifying with
happening to someone
yeah and i mean we could add a fourth
one actually are you seeking
are you seeing me nice
yeah
cool i like that
because
if uh if there's no suffering there's no
seeking no self and no subject or no
duality then
the natural state seems to be operating
the show
um
and if any of those things are
in place then there's further let's say
investigation
um
yeah
yeah for the freedom
to feel yeah
yeah it's not like work you know as long
as you're looking at it like oh there's
more seeking to do i've got more i need
to do more inquiry damn it you might as
well just
just stop right there and go do
something else and come back when you
actually feel like
finding out what you are you know
sincerely because you're already right
off on the wrong foot if you're thinking
of it as like a job or like oh it's so
much effort to like loosen the center i
really need to sit you have a partner
for eight hours to stop you know that in
itself is a paradigm
just release that and then you're
already more free than you would have
been eight hours into vipassana yeah
or is a bumblebee in my room
yeah
so it really takes honesty it takes
i've heard idea refer to honesty as
something really important and before
this i was like oh yeah he's just being
idea you know i just very um
what's like subjective level he's very
homey very sweet with people's problems
and i thought that honesty was one of
those things you know yeah be honest
obviously be a good person whatever
but no it's pointing to a radical
honesty within yourself about where you
are exactly yeah
yeah and you can't you can't deny
your experience
you know it takes honesty to look at
your experience and say i am still
seeking
or i am still suffering i've just been
putting a mental overlay on my suffering
but i am still suffering
that is really strong to be able to do
that to be able to open yourself to the
idea that you have inquiry to do or that
you're further exploring you know like
you said further freedom
that is incredible and that's why it's
so rare
because it's comfortable you know is
awakening comfortable for you if it's if
it's comfortable it's not it man
you know if you're comfortable in your
paradigm if you're comfortable oh yes
i'm done
this is uh yeah this i'm done i'm happy
as awareness
that comfort is illusory that's the
comfort of the mind i don't think i'm
ever comfortable anymore you know in
terms of concepts i have no idea what to
do or say
and that's the beauty of it it's like
you the next moment you have no idea
yeah it's so fresh you don't know what
you are yeah it's so fresh
it's it's stale to think you're
something
it gets old
stop thinking yourself
you are your true nature is the absence
of being a thing
that's what you are the absence of being
something
[Music]
and you can feel the freedom
you tune into that
you feel the liberation
yeah it's just the absence the absence
of something absence of resistance
the absence of a plan
it's just
creating itself
on the spot moment to moment
and that's also you know why we can be
so casual about this you know we we know
we not trying to be anything anymore
god imagine you're trying to be
something imagine that imagine caring
imagine
and this is just so freeing you know for
the first time you don't need to be
anything because you are already it so
just suspend all of that
you're done you're
done um
yeah
the freedom of not being a thing
yeah that that came to me and i thought
yeah it is that
because it took six months you know for
for that to
to come because for for six months i had
no clue
and then i was like oh
you are not nothing you are not
emptiness you are not awareness all of
these things are like it's not it's not
an
oh
you're the absence of being something
that's what you
that's why we can't catch it
that's why none of the labels fit that's
that's why if you're caught in a label
it's a paradigm and you can move out of
it because you're not a thing and we've
heard that but we still
somehow make that into a thing we're
like oh i'm not a thing
that's the thing i am i'm nothing i'm
nothing
but no you're the absence of being
anything
anything
that's going to be the
the thumbnail
with your picture
the absence of being a thing
davey
i agree i really like it i really like
it it's it's my only true wisdom from
this
this whole thing it's like the one thing
that i'm like okay cool we'll go with
that
everything else just gets discarded
it's like no you are lying you're lying
yeah i love how
clearly that
just
resonates with the word freedom
the absence of being a thing freedom
um
and i love how you brought up audio and
honesty and before we started recording
when you
and when you shared about the
paradigmlessness
and then immediately what came through
because there's no self image that wants
to be seen a specific way so then
there's the ability for the intelligence
to just channel through and so the way
that i responded the way that it
responded to itself was that
there's simultaneously right now here
the feeling of paradigmlessness and yet
at the same time there's the
the occasional
um
mental proliferation we could say
um in the pali
buddhism it's called papanka
it's like mental conceptualization and
mental proliferation around a sense of
self self image the world others stories
and so then there's a weaving right
that's what the
nibana nirvana
is the unweaving or the unfabricating
and so when you weave and when you
fabricate and you can create a sense of
contrast between those two and just
relax more and more in the unweaved
in the unfabricated
um in the empty in the hollow and then
over time though the weaviness
the webbiness
that that dependent arising-ness
of self-others world stories relaxes
more and more dissolves more and more
and then
so that's this honesty right that's just
this honesty it isn't
the the atlas
character or finger of the universal
hand doesn't need to appear any specific
way to with the other fingers to be
valid
right to be worthy
and so
that's freedom right that's freedom too
yeah
yeah trying to be anything other than
what you are is resisting what is
anything whether you're trying to
i don't know you're trying to become
something i mean go for it but you're
resisting what you are
let the becoming be what you are when
you're becoming it don't think i need to
be this way
i need to be seen in i don't know like i
need to be seen as a teacher whatever oh
my goodness imagine i
i would have thought like i can't open
for the the wasp i was there because i
need to see more like spiritual i need
to sit still but there's a wasp
so i was like hey i don't need to
pretend anymore just go open for the
thing
they set it free whatever they were both
free
you know
just yeah don't resist don't resist what
you are we we just have these problems
whether they're like superficial on like
the level of the person i need to look
different
i need to
be more intelligent i need to have
better abilities at hobbies all the way
to you know i need to become even more
solidified in my awareness identity i
need to become even more integrated and
enlightened
you know bro you are you are it you are
the perfect
manifestation of what is
and okay within reason because sometimes
we need to believe that we need to
improve to get to see this right we all
we're always seekers believing we need
to really get somewhere i really need to
abide as awareness starting now i'm
gonna do it the whole day we had to do
that we had to for a certain amount of
time believe we need to be something
else we had to believe we need to become
it until we saw oh oh damn now i guess
i've always been perfect
yes i've always been loved
damn i've always been the perfect
program there's never been a problem
with me now what now now i'm gonna have
so much free time
i've always been perfect there's never
been a problem with me
and believing that was resisting the
fact that i'm perfect
that everyone is perfect and unique
believing that i had to change was just
a mask over that so that i didn't see it
in the absence of the belief i need to
be something different what am i i'm
perfect because it's only the belief i
need to be something else that creates
that reality
it's you know your thoughts and your
belief systems
so much of manifest is created just from
that
if you're believing something in a
moment that is your experience in that
moment
guaranteed if you believe i'm insecure
wow you feel insecure wow what a
surprise
throw away that thought then what are
you
secure
safe protected loved perfect divine
and you are exactly where you're
supposed to be
because everyone thinks i need to be
something better i need to be somewhere
else i need to be doing better in my job
my relationship
sure holds relative truth
in some cases but normally no you don't
just stop thinking that stop thinking
that and see the perfection underneath
your ridiculous belief
so it's it's like you you now get to
know your perfection for the first time
the person never existed so the person
never disappears and so therefore this
illusory person can finally know its
perfection it can finally stop trying to
lose weight it can finally stop trying
to work harder than it wants to or can
pushing itself to the limit because even
this illusory person now says oh damn
i truly am a divine creation and i'm
exactly where i'm supposed to be at this
point in time and it could not be any
other way
and that's the case for everyone it's
just that some people are not seeing it
yet and they need to believe they need
to become
for a bit
until you see oh wow
no i don't
yeah
oh man um
one of the things that uh bintino masaro
and the no limit society uh team as well
as community are really um
focused on as a
as a paradigm for liberation let's say
is the three or four body system
so we have the the physical
the subtle the causal and then if you
will the great causal or the i am body
the awareness love and light
and it's
what you're describing right now is so
beautiful because at the causal level
is where all the assumptions and the
beliefs are seated
and
they
propagate into the subtle into the mind
and into the physical
so at that seed level if you will use
this
beautiful visualization of this system
that so perfectly we could say mirrors
the way that
trees also blossom from seeds out and to
fruits
so very similarly
and so if the right nourishment isn't
there at that seed level of that you're
i'm already whole i'm already free
i'm already one with it all
um i'm already empty and hollow of any
need to try and get external validation
and whatnot then that will appear as the
fruits in the physical appear in in the
space of your awareness and
consciousness
but if there are these unwhole unworthy
um lacking separate
local into the body thoughts
um that are at the seed level
constructs if you will
then those will operate the show
and that's what we've been calling like
the gremlin or the hitchhiker
and so you can really feel that
uh on your nervous system like when not
only for yourself but for when you're
around your other selves you can really
feel it when it's operating the show
and so the liberation
is
a process of inquiry into where did i
pick up the belief or the assumption
and then that could also be called what
real shadow work actually is yeah
yeah yeah
yeah very interesting again you know
before this i negated shadow work
because i thought there's no person the
person doesn't exist why do i need to
deal with a person's problems uh
no i'm not gonna i'm just gonna meditate
and i'm gonna negate this thing's
existence then after the shift i was
like oh wow what are these sensations
what what is this like that feels like
trauma
it's weird because that's just in the
body it's been cut loose of any
suffering
so it's a very unusual case whereas
normally people do shadow work as part
of like spirituality before awakening or
they'll take the progressive path um i
kind of jumped into awakening it was
very fast
um and then like a year and a half later
this the the final shift happened and so
i didn't do any shadow work i i didn't i
left the character completely messed up
traumatized and uh all kinds of things
feeling inadequate and after the shift i
was like what is this like feeling of uh
not good enough what is going on because
it doesn't make any sense
and so i've now realized that this this
this is an integral integral part of
awakening
i would have thought that it's separate
you know my biased awareness mind would
have thought now that shadow work that's
for the person what i'm doing is the
real world i'm getting enlightened but
no that's not how it works there are two
sides of the same coin
so only now has this character started
to investigate its thoughts and belief
systems um about regarding inadequacy
and so on because they don't they don't
click with the experience anymore
there's a very clear experience that
everything is perfect but then there's a
sensation in the throat of fear
and like a narrative passing through the
head of like i'm not good enough and
it's completely foreign
there's no longer this like thing that's
believing it to be true it's not holding
it together but i was like this is so
weird is this what i was thinking about
myself
that's insane so now you know shadow
work great and i'm starting to think
like
these are the beliefs that were
governing my outward behavior my whole
life and i didn't know i only see it now
nice and you see it now and and you know
i should have before but
it is what it is but it's it's integral
integral integral it's it's so important
that the person gets aligned with its
true nature as well as like the the
perspective shift
because you you're just gonna have be
like a mess of a person within the
natural state
don't even don't do that you want a
holistic full aligned
like creatorship
uh experience
you don't want to feel inadequate within
an enlightened framework you don't want
to that's not pleasant don't ignore the
person
it doesn't exist anyways
so exactly like what you said these
these seeds that are planted if you
plant the inadequacy seed
what do you think is going to happen on
the outside
obviously your your entire circumstances
are going to paint that picture for you
because it's mirroring you
if i believe on the inside i'm not good
enough everything on the outside is
going to tell me the same thing because
reality is a mirror yes if i am empty
reality is empty
that's another thing i realize with the
recent shift that this is just like i've
heard bentino say
smoke and mirrors yes it's that's all it
is
and so you can go right down to like
your fundamental belief that's causing
you some kind of friction or suffering
or whatever whether that's like i lack
something i'm not good enough
i need to be something else i need other
people to validate me i need attention
all of those can be traced back
to an
often an event
often years ago you've been carrying
this for 20 30 years
and for some reason as soon as you see
that
like i was telling my boyfriend
yesterday as soon as you see
this event cause this reaction it's no
longer the current thing that's causing
it you're like oh
this started way before this person
pissed me off
this feeling started 20 years ago it's
not because this person said something
to me it's got nothing to do with this
the circumstances are just painting the
picture from 20 years ago and that
belief got put in my head somehow
and so as soon as you see that it
already starts to unearth itself it's
like
oh so this doesn't tie to this which
means i'm i'm not inadequate in this
situation
and it starts to unravel
and then you become empty first and then
you become full you know so it's first
like yes
you're so caught up and you're so
contracted and you feel like you're not
good enough and then you're like
okay
then there's emptiness
and there's just like this hollow
like then what am i as a person
that's when like the fulfillment starts
what i am is perfect what i am is good
enough and you you unearth those like
initial
seeds or ideas or concepts replace them
with something way more aligned to what
you actually are way more aligned to
your goal and
um just your mission here and
it just flourishes it's like thank
goodness now you're giving now it's true
it's and because it's true it it just
out pause you know these these
contracted energies seem to like stay
stagnant it's just constant
experience like victimizing you and you
stay so small and you feel like you're
not enough and i need to get people to
like me and
as soon as you just let go of that the
truth of yourself that you are perfect
just bursts open and it takes over your
entire experience
because it's true if anything is true
it'll resonate it'll flourish and it'll
feel good it'll feel good if it feels
bad question it it's yeah it's not
aligned you're believing something
that's not true
yeah
yeah
and then using those feelings those
emotions as guidance
we've been talking about it like a
guidance system like the feelings and
the emotions the
energetics are themselves a guidance
system and so if there is a feeling
of suffering or feeling bad that it's
typically a contraction in the sense of
identity
that there's an assumption of a sense of
self a sense of other's world and
getting lost in stories or at the seed
level that there's an assumption or a
belief of unworthiness and then in the
physical manifest level
everything's like you said reflective
and mirror like to that assumption or
the belief
and so the dissolving or the dislodging
or the transmuting of those beliefs and
assumptions
is exactly what enables freedom from the
contracted sense of identity and then
by doing that we see in the physical in
the manifest is reflected to us
that beauty the perfection
um the
non-locality also
and that's
such a crucial piece
to this is that the
it's a feeling that's sort of it's so
difficult to describe you you mentioned
how
um even space and time um
just seemed to be very dreamlike
just happening as a singularity of sorts
and no
time and no space
um
and so
there's this feeling of in a sense
being the intelligence that is speaking
and listening to itself at the same time
right now and this sort of
uh
happening
as just manifestation
um
and
that already being free and not already
being perfect and
and then yeah and then there's a total
like relaxation because of that
yeah
and it's really important to feel again
like the simultaneity of
that
everything already being perfect and
free and yet also recognizing that yes
there are we could say other selves that
don't have their basic needs being met
or that still live in very violent areas
and that
there is still a perfecting
that this collective is undergoing in
terms of meeting the basic needs of all
and
having peace
true peace
with no violence and no
total abandonment of weapons of mass
destruction
and things like that
um
and so that the simultaneity is
beautiful there because then you can
still
really radiate out the bodhisattva vibe
that it can radiate itself out into the
collective
um
because it's that's exactly what it's
seeking if you're tuned into the
collective you can feel that what it's
seeking is its own liberation is its own
awakening
um
is the end of the assumptions and the
beliefs that have been plaguing the
collective for millennia of separation
and lack
etc
yeah
yeah
um
to
to live on absolute level means to not
negate any subjectivity
so if you are truly and wholly
integrated
in your clarity you will not deny the
suffering of others you will not deny
that people are not getting their needs
met
that they are calls to service in the
world if you're denying any of that
you're not clear
because
you're denying something this is a whole
acceptance on all levels like yes i
accept things as they are in that
people are suffering there are people
are not getting their needs met however
acceptance does not imply indifference
and it doesn't imply nonchalance and it
does not imply that there's no call to
service
so
again contradictory to my beliefs before
because i was thinking hey there's no
there's no one suffering so it's fine
the kids in africa it's it's fine
because god allows it
yeah it's it's that's a denial it's a
denial of the humanity in you
if you see someone suffering
that whether you have a self or not
you're going to feel oh my goodness
you're going to feel that heaviness here
and you can't deny that so that's what
drives this
call to service
our humanity our humanity acting
simultaneously with our clarity and our
awakening
and we just somehow intuitively know
that we can't deny this that we have to
help
it just feels like
and there's no other way to explain it
because it can be negated so fast by
like non-radical non-dualists
um if i say anything it can be negated
if i say no but i really feel like i
need to help they'll say it's just a
story
but it's felt it's felt as a deep sense
of
i am
almost
obliged
to
help
the end of suffering in
any way that i can
and denying that is painful it's it's
resisting and it's it's contracted
it's contracted so
again these stories that non-dual
paradigm and the non-dual community
tells itself
there's no self so everyone can suffer
doesn't matter it's god's plan you know
throw all of that away and you will go
help that person on the street throw
away your story
you know you will you will give
50 to the beggar what what are you doing
you're ignoring your humanity and your
man your humanity itself is divine there
is no separation there's no separation
between your humanity and your empathy
and call to service and the absolute
they are one and the same just like
through and through you know on almost
like on levels
if the absolute is here it's like
funnels down
kind of into the being and the act of
service and and it just should not be
negated by all these stories
non-dual people say hey don't tell
yourself a story but they're telling
themselves to the story
and i don't mean to come off like i'm
you know contradicting on reality
absolutely not because it's what brought
me here but
there's just so much that
like
bentino and you and the team are kind of
ripping apart in terms of
spirituality and non-duality because on
the outside it's like oh they're
following a story that people need to be
helped come on but
there's a deep felt sense that that is
true
that humanity is moving toward a global
awakening
and you can't tell someone that who
doesn't feel it because it sounds like a
story in the same way that enlightenment
sounds like a story oh yeah you feel
blissful all the time you're right
you can't explain it unless you feel it
and if you feel call to service and to
end suffering then it's aligned i
believe
yes and
and not only the call to service to end
suffering
but also what
and the freedom for
um all of the
the blocked energy
to just contraction those contractions
to be liberated but then also on this
collective level
what actual paradise or heaven on earth
truly feels like when
all basic needs are met and when all are
able to actualize whatever creative
artistic expressions that they desire
and true creatorhood
and
where
that
we've been calling it shambhala
and
to just to really feel into what would
it be like to have
millions and billions of people
be in total freedom and sovereignty and
artistic expression
um with all needs be met and just so
abundant and prosperous
um why
the [ __ ] would we not
have that be the core of the north star
for this collective
and yeah yeah
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely if if
you say anything else you're in
ignorance i'm afraid you know we all
want to be in
a circumstance that is embodied and
aligned and everyone
feels
perfect and no one feels lack and
everyone feels safe
of course and absolutely true absolutely
true
and i just realized that you know
a holistic integrated approach to that
is
while
knowing that
this is the goal right you you know and
you tuned into the shambhala frequency
and
you're embodying that circumstance so
that you know the circumstances can
follow through
there's also a part of you that has to
know that everything as it is it's
perfect already otherwise you're already
off on the wrong foot again you know if
you're thinking that there's lack here
like oh people are suffering and
i need to i need to change this to get
to shambhala that's not going to work
because the basis of manifestation
collective uh shifts is shambhala is
here now now and you know yes in a way
you have to negate
um these circumstances that tell you
that's not the case if you truly want a
free
community free society free earth
um
you have to know that this is exactly
right
and so it's like a balance between the
two you can't find lack now
you can't find like an and that's kind
of where
the awakening thing comes in because if
you awaken and then you act toward this
goal of like a perfect society you've
already got that paradigm paradigm for
the sake of the word that everything is
perfect as it is it's your experience
right now that despite the suffering
despite the contradictions to the fact
that this is not ideal everything is
perfect and that is what accelerates the
manifestation so that's why
same this is the reason why enlightened
people tend to manifest the things that
they want because it's not coming from a
place of lack so the more enlightened
beings let's say come together
in this mentality of and in this
experience of everything is perfect as
it is whilst envisioning embodying the
ideal society in which everyone feels a
certain way
it's the perfect accelerated vehicle
to
change outward circumstances and to
really get this ideal
state going yeah so it's yeah absolutely
powerful
this is already heaven on earth or
paradise on earth or shambhala is
already like the frequency or the state
that we choose to occupy
and at the same time we recognize that
there is a more and more basic needs
being met the more and more
actualization of the shambhala
vision and so because of that
we
we take let's say 2035 or whatnot and we
have the feeling of what that feels like
now
and
then there's no lack there's no lack in
what is now and there's no lack and
we're not there yet and then that's what
like you said it makes the blossoming of
it
exact
precise um without any lack or without
any self
um
and then
that's what makes it pure in its service
also
yeah and it makes us able to dance our
way there to like
like playfully dance
all the way
yeah absolutely
absolutely
because yeah
it's complete embodiment of perfection
so there's no longer any resistance to
it
and um again you know even this even the
vision of a better society a better
earth
the one shouldn't negate it
you know don't don't negate it because i
used to think this in the dream and out
of the dream
no now that vision for a better society
is in the dream
news flash there is only the dream buddy
yeah so absolutely absolutely
it's totally important and you know if
you say that that kind of thing is not
important global awakening is not
important okay what is
if we want to say that's not then
nothing is
you know
nothing is
so that's for the sake of
this experience if we have to call
something important i'd say it's this
nice
and being a vehicle for it
yes i love how we can
um hollow ourselves to
total mystery and freedom and like
nothing being important and then from
there what is important the first thing
the only thing is global awakening and
so then there's that simultaneity of
that and
so good yeah
it's it's it's like a metaphor for
everything that's happening here at the
same time you know it's perfect but
there's a pursuit of
perfection
and at the same time you know that
source does not care whether people are
awake to itself or not
yet you're teaching people so it's this
play of absolute wisdom and this
embodiment of humanity and
service and it's beautiful it's
beautiful and that's like true um
integration it's it's a crystalline
experience
and it's um
[Music]
you're not you're simply not in denial
of anything you're not in denial of any
level that's all basically
yeah
yeah acceptance of all levels right from
the person all the way to your utmost
clarity of no thing
yes
yeah that that true simultaneity of all
of those
um
is what i would say is like the most
um super positioned or the most
entangled um
recognition of the nature and then
um that's what sort of enables a
um a relaxation because
when the absolute and the relative are
seen to be entangled in one and then the
empty fullness is able to be entangled
in one or the human and the god or
however it wants to be
um portrayed or the perfection and
perfecting
um that
that entangled superposition if you will
um
it is uh
it's so juicy it's so
um
it's liberating it's liberating because
you can feel that this is already
freedom
and yet also you can truly feel
the heart of the other self that feels
contracted in a sense of self that
doesn't feel free and then to serve that
freedom yeah so that entangledness um it
prevents us from falling into
um a single dimension or a single uh
construct or position
um
and so to stay entangled or to stay
super positioned
is uh highly advantageous it's very
shapeshifter like it's very
what i've noticed is um
[Music]
some of the most uh awake and some of
the most present to
the natural state is like that
yeah
yeah you go from being
contracted enlightened to
organic and enlightened and you don't
care what you are
when i when that shift happened the most
one of the most
i'd say things that i stood out the most
was the organic
biological
um flowing nature of this
because
the awareness thing although it's vast
and expensive and
beautiful
is a rigid structure
and when a paradigm like that is let go
of you come into this organic
shape-shifting nature
like if you turn your head you've you've
shape-shifted into the entire room yep
you know
and no matter what you do whether you're
cooking teaching
you're literally shape-shifting into
that activity you are no longer
something keeping its form while other
things happen to or around
so it's it's a complete
surrender
and and knowing that i don't ever need
to be anything but very deeply very very
deeply so that you can
almost metaphysically
take the shape of different things and
different experiences
so that shape-shifting quality is
i've heard frank mention it before as
well
and again that was something that i
didn't feel before i was like okay i
guess theoretically i can see awareness
is
manifesting as all of this and so
therefore shape-shifting but that is a
different
thing to the actual experience of like
we said turning one's head and oh my god
i became the room from this angle
it's and and this shape-shifting quality
although this is the basic example
is just what you are throughout
everything throughout service throughout
fun
or activities you're just
like this organic mush with no border no
center that's just becoming whatever is
happening yeah
it's stunning yes
and to not have something like calling
the shots anymore you know there's no
longer thing that it's like
i don't know trying to mold this thing
trying to change the experience into
some other shape you are happy with
whatever this experience appears to be
and there's no longer you can't even say
you are the experience because there is
no you to be the experience and you can
even say there is no experience because
i don't know there's no space no time
what do you want to call this then
you know so it's just like this totally
organic thing and i remember comparing
it to like a
a star almost or like something like a
star burning or a star exploding or like
a black hole the organic nature of that
feels very similar to this
because that thing is something
marvelous magnificent but that lacks
agency it doesn't have an individual
thing that's orchestrating its
magnificent
show that it's putting on the burning
and that's how this feels
there's no longer this thing that's like
oh i need to burn brighter tomorrow and
less bright the day after batman
you're just this organic biological
function flourishing flourishing like a
star or a black hole
nice yeah it's a great
way to tie the macrocosm to the
microcosm because it's
the natural state is
the way that the black hole in the sun
and the planets orbiting the different
stars that
that's how that operates
and as raw would say the law of one that
that's the logos that that's the very
intentionality for the creator to know
itself and that
we are that same
organic biological function of the
creator knowing itself on the microcosm
in the mind body spirit complex
expression and it's just so clear that
um that that there's like that
natural organic mushy
um
blossoming unfoldment
that
um
[Music]
that there's
there's nothing better than than to be
totally free and to just be um
to like be that and to
let the mystery move and also have a
good idea at the same time of what you
truly are
um
and
to
um so yeah just be a humble servant
with no name
and
to
[Music]
just
laugh like laugh and play
also so much like
we love that as as our team
um
so there's like of course there's this
like
exciting navy seals or viking energy and
then there's also this very relaxed like
buddhist
meditative
energy
and then there's this like laughter in
this dance and this play also
this hilarity
and
even
we know it's so true but when you're
laughing hysterically with um close
friends i mean
there's no time
[Laughter]
yeah
there's no
yeah
yeah the experience of fun and the
experience of beauty and the experience
of love
and therefore friendship and things like
that
you are completely immersed in your true
self there's nothing that wants anything
to be different than it is
there's
there's no
name there there's no character there
that you're completely immersed in the
other or the experience to such an
extent that there is no you
and that's why these experiences are so
um
you can say like significant to us why
we want to have fun why we want to
have love and friends and community
because these acts
resemble ourselves
there are
little
manifestations or like little examples
little like prototypes of true nature
little glimpses you could say
and
they they're good to model after you
know they're they're because this this
state this true
final whatever it is
is very similar
to
you know a deep love a deep intimacy
um
yeah you you kind of feel like you're
you're constantly on the edge of i don't
know sometimes it feels like you're
being tickled in a way you're like ready
to laugh at any point you know
it's it's just like exhilarating and
you're on edge and it's spontaneous and
those are all the things that you feel
with friends when you see something you
really like or when you're super excited
and that's i can't think of anything
else that life is for
in terms of the human experience
now that you know all the things have
been shattered all the ideas of you
should be this type of way you should
become an enlightened guru teacher to an
ashram all of that
since that dissolved it's like oh no
this is actually just to have this
experience of
like fun
you know the this your higher self if
you want to call it that is not invested
in any of your petty issues any of your
goals anything like that it's it's
literally just you know embodying as
this character for now to have fun
it's like it's like summer camp for it
in a way
and if you tune into yourself you feel
that you embody that and you can feel oh
wow none of this is serious i wish i'd
known this
none of this is serious again while
simultaneously knowing okay they are
they are serious issues that need my
help
but inherently
i can just laugh i can just have fun
because that's what this is for now
there's nothing else there's nothing
else than being happy there's nothing
nothing nothing else
you know
we just thought there was something else
we thought there was something other
than pure creative fun but there isn't
and it's
beautiful yeah
yes
so good i love how you called it the
summer camp for higher self it's so cute
you know we're busy stressing like oh my
god i need to do this
which is lost in the you know the camp
activities kind of it's like i really
need to do this team building in a way
that's going to be constructed but we
just forget why we're here we're here to
have fun
and the more you're tuned into your
higher self the more you know that and
you embody it and the least you're
entering your higher self the the more
problems you perceive the more you feel
like this is not what i came for why am
i here
the more you lose sight of the fun thing
you know
so it's great it's great and all of this
stuff happens simultaneously again like
none of this is not enlightenment like
higher self and degrees of consciousness
it is it is to say it's not is to imply
a duality so yeah tune into your higher
self c let your higher self give you
clarity according to what you like as to
what you are and become enlightened stop
negating your tools you have a higher
self that's not a belief just go see for
yourself and you'll see
and these oh there are all these
available things that can help you
but we all follow like this thing we're
all like a buddhist or an idolist or a
spiritualist and we don't like
mix them you know before i was like i
don't have a higher self everything's
empty
it's not true
it's not true
nice
nice
we're here for fun so good
so good
yeah because why create uh separation um
when we talk about um
like
one that um most recently especially in
like let's say the last half year that
was just so transformative was
recognizing the similarity between
um
no self and capital s self
and
realizing the similarity between that
and
the one infinite creator
and just seeing
how
there is only that with itself and that
is made of love it's made of fun
um of light
and
to
to be able to draw these these um
[Music]
these pointings
uh
together
and to
find that that commonality
um
it creates the most you could say
like
awake surface area so there's no uh like
leaks or holes or wobbles that are
possible where we can get stuck in a
specific paradigm or way
because we've in a sense developed um
because we both want no map or no
concepts and yet at the same time we do
have a map we do have concepts that we
reference to which is how we literally
speak
to each other
and
so then for that map to be as holistic
as possible with the pinnacle pointings
across these different mystic lineages
as well as social memory complexes
things like this
this is one of the best approaches
yeah it's it's a it's like a holistic
embodiment of all of those that you
mentioned
no self with a small s
and then self with the big s which is
the universal shared consciousness and
then you can add no self with the big s
so it's while simultaneously knowing
that you are not even big self you know
you're not even that you are not even
the collective shared awareness
consciousness bliss
while knowing you are it and you're also
no small self
or small self you know as you play
so it's this play of like
the
simultaneity again of these three levels
knowing you are the absence of being a
thing whilst knowing that you are
awareness god consciousness
and then the absence of a person
and they together create this
optimum functioning you could say
it's like you're you're functioning your
your unit is functioning in like ideal
specs
yeah that way
it's what it feels like
and you can't just choose like you can't
just
you can't just choose to like live as
like no small self because you're just
gonna feel like nothing then you know
you're missing something you're missing
a degree of
uh empowerment and clarity and power and
so on so that's why you're like oh
i'm big self i'm god i'm consciousness
i'm awareness and that creates it
replaces all your inadequacy beliefs
and it it destroys whatever messed up
thing you had going on before and then
you realize you're not even that and
from there you can play freely across
this like spectrum as much as you like
because you're not you don't claim to be
anything anymore nice yep
beautiful
yeah and then the
you can be moved
the body mind can be moved by the
intelligence so you as the intelligence
can move the body-mind
organically naturally effortlessly to
exactly where it needs to be on this
spectrum of the simultaneity of all
levels
and
yeah
it's so freeing
and there's depending on the situation
you know sorry
just like i just loved how there wasn't
like a stuckness because that's normally
what would happen is there would be like
a stuckness
that would then at one of those like
levels a shape-shift to a level then
there'd be some sort of stuckness and
that's where usually the sense of like
oh this paradigm or oh my sense of
self-image or
my i'm too deep in a story or i'm too
deep listening to another self-story and
now i'm ruminating on it and then
there's a liberation from that back to
this whole spectrum-ness
yeah yeah
yeah for a while we seem to fluctuate
like that a little bit you know
for a while you feel like you're stuck
in something especially so now you get
into an argument with someone that's
very like uh intense and you feel oh no
i'm i'm in the other self ego and and
you feel oh i need to i need to shift
back into alignment or whatever but you
know very soon if you let that happen
you're like oh that that was also it you
know that argument was
it was fine it was fine i didn't need to
go anywhere and
it's a manifestation of this this play
across this like thing you were just
simply down there for a little while
you're not stuck you're about to bounce
back up relax
you know and that's just a play of
experience experience will always keep
changing
you will never ever ever just be one
thing like we said earlier you're the
absence of being something so stop
trying to stick to one thing stop trying
to be aligned in every moment because
you are resisting the
experience of non-alignment so-called
non-alignment you just need to see that
that's not non-alignment
you know within reason obviously always
room for improvement and so on becoming
better and more holistic
but
the yeah there shouldn't be any
stuckness in the experience
eventually
at first it'll be like that it will be
i'm not abiding or
i wish i could shift back into that
expansive
place that i was in earlier but now this
argument has contracted me but
eventually you're just like oh this
argument contracted me and then very
shortly after that you're expansive
again
because that's just how we are again we
shape-shift we will shape-shift and we
will mirror an ego ego
and we'll contract to communicate with
them because that's the nature of our
communication we communicate on their
level and that's not something to be
like condemned you're not if you're not
hurting anyone
and things like that so yeah it's an
embracing of this organic shape-shifting
thing and a non-resistance not trying to
say like i want to be in this shape i
want to be in the expansive shape i want
to be in the guard shape
no you are in your absolute shape in all
of those
another
facet to that that i find
so perfect is that
the
team we've been
sharing that it can feel like one eye
is on
the what's present what is organically
being shape-shifted to
and then one eye if you will is kind of
clocked back on the entire spectrum
itself
and there is a there's a power to that
because even though it can feel like
part of the energy
is
on um
whether it be
a conversation or um
or someone feeling contracted and then
you're being asked to help provide a
good question to help them feel more
free and liberated
that at the same time there's part of
your energy one eye clocked back at i am
already um totally free and that um
as though um there's one eye that is
aware of the dream even while
um
the other eye is like balls deep in
the dream
yeah
yeah it's a it's a really good analogy
it it feels like that
experientially
yeah yeah you never lose yourself you
don't whatever happens you can't lose
yourself because like you said that
other eyes pointed toward the point of
clarity no matter what happens in the
experience
what you are is not an experience and
something knows that something i don't
know what it is but something is pointed
toward that at all times so experience
can go wild you can do whatever the heck
you want man because something knows
itself something knows this framework in
which experience is happening is not an
experience this framework can never ever
change
it can never ever ever ever change and
it can never get lost in anything it can
never lose itself any of these paradigms
not really
and so we once we see that we seem to
maintain that space or framework
and no matter what happens no matter
what shape this takes no matter if we
get involved with another person or not
contract or not it remains within this
like
non-lens of
perfection and wholeness
and
infinite
capacity and
creation
and that's one hell of a solid framework
for anything to happen
nothing can take that down
nothing
you know if you think you're like you
got enlightenment and you lost it that's
experience
you simply cannot lose enlightenment you
can't lose true enlightenment you can't
because once you see it it's always
going to be that framework that the one
eye points back to
and you always see that while you're
involved in the play
there is the clarity of what you are and
that's not even a duality it's not like
there's a separation between oh i'm
playing this role but i'm also that is
that's not how it's felt in the
experience it's a simultaneous
um
yeah like again that mush
but yeah very good analogy very good
analogy there's always something
pointing
toward the true nature of things no
matter what happens in the foreground
yeah nice
it's very nice that one can talk about
this now you know
it's the perfect timing even this
you know there's a reason that even this
like discussion didn't happen before
because there was probably some kind of
disconnect or something
paradigm and paradigm you know it would
have
but this this there's a like a mutual
shared
agreement that
whatever the hell this is is
and it is all there is
yes
and
it is
more
freedom with itself rather than
what could have been maybe several
months ago
when we were first exploring doing this
what could have been um a little bit
more con slight contractions showing up
so
it is uh it's really nice
yeah this is entirely free
entirely entirely free perfect
embodiment
yeah yeah as long as you're stuck in
anything you will have a contracted
space or contracted energy
um
and
you can deny it if you like
but only for so long
before you realize how damn i am
contracted
there's a sense of something here that
is not integrated that's not ready
that's not
um that's fearful or lack based
any of that
the thing that wants to get something
the thing that wants to be something
different
any little glimmer of that
to just be looked at
because if you have a subject all you
need to do is turn it into an object
it's that simple whether that be like
psychologically like a with an
attachment
like i believe that if i lose my
i don't know my favorite item i'm going
to fill a loss of myself that's an
attachment you have a self in that item
you know just sever the ties
see that that's an object
same goes for anything else the the self
that's claiming to be inadequate the
self is claiming to be
anything
turn it around look at it as soon as you
look at it it can't say anything because
it's now an object and who's the agency
then
then you're in agencylessness
and that's basically like i guess the
idea of all of this
um yeah like it comes back to those like
three or four things that we said
if you're suffering there's something
there's an experiencer
there's an experience there's a subject
there's a self
if you're seeking
just look just turn it around just look
at that thing that's pretending to look
at everything else and then you level
the playing field
and then you see it's only ever been
objects of experience we're all objects
of experience
god knows how that works
but
it's true
yeah
how infinite manifestation
works
yeah for no one
for no one and for nothing
you know it's even a slight stretch to
say that it's it's manifesting for
itself because it's not even doing that
it's even less
caring than that it's like
i'm just doing what i'm doing for nobody
not even for me i'm manifesting not even
for any perceiver i'm not even
manifesting for someone to enjoy it
on relative level yeah the people can
enjoy the experience but on absolute
level there's no one here to enjoy
what's happening and that's what's so
beautiful about it's like creating art
for nobody to see
you know you know that the art has been
created and you left it in a desert
somewhere and it'll never ever be seen
and but that's the beauty of it for
nobody it's just the creation
just the spontaneity
no goal
it's just that in itself
nope doesn't serve a purpose
the purpose if anything was the creating
of the art
for no one
hmm
[Music]
i love how
in the lob one
there's the
the creator will know itself
as the you could say the explanation of
the infinite manifestation
and then i also love like you shared the
infinite manifestation being for no one
and
being like making an incredible
universe
with all of its epic dance
knowing itself expressing itself
but then that also being
in a
in a painting in a desert
and
to really be able to like feel that
it um
it's just no better word than yeah than
freedom and
like i guess peace is another really
good one for it it's peace
also um
yeah and entirely causes
causeless and
goalless
pure
spontaneity it's a human thing to
believe that something exists for
something else
you know we do one thing for another
person or
we do something so that we can feel
better about ourselves this cause and
effect thing it's human
that's not our true nature operates
it's not operating
for anything
and
because of that can be said to be pure
innocence
like if a child is playing the child's
not playing for anyone
the child is playing
there's nothing more to be said about it
the child isn't even really playing for
itself
because the child doesn't really have
that sense of like gain reward it's just
impulses pleasure in the body whatever
that's not it's not directed toward
anyone
and that's a
manifestation of pure innocence and this
is just that on a
massive scale
yeah it's a massive massive innocent
creation
and
seeing that is what really liberates
because you can then embody
that viewpoint on your level of the
person
and you can see that what's happening
now is the goal
this is it yes you're not striving for
anything in the same way that
the infinite creator is not creating for
anything
except for just the creation itself you
are existing here now purely for the
fact that you are existing here now and
that is what gives you inherent worth
that is what gives you inherent capacity
to love to experience happiness and
peace
because it's not about a cause and
effect it's not about living for
something
or trying to become something in the end
or anything like that it's it's been
this moment from the start this moment
has been the prize from the very
beginning just for the sake of nothing
what who cares but who knows what it's
for
but
that's that's such freedom because you
no longer need to believe that
anything else exists anything else is
important other than what is happening
hands off the wheel
beautiful
yeah
the microcosm
of child-like
innocence
as the macrocosm of universal innocence
of the
infinite manifestation being totally
innocent and
um
yeah i love agencylessness that's so
good also
and i like how you also mentioned how
it's like this from
the very
beginningless beginning
um this innocence
um this fun
um
and that's why um
yeah it's
that's why frank also says this a lot
that it's like
natural state is very much like the
the child-like innocence
the grandparent like wisdom
um the sage-like
purity
the monkey-like
natural spontaneousness
yeah all merged together also an a.i
all merged together
so perfect it's it's everything it's
everything and you know the spontaneity
just comes from
again like not believing that you should
be doing something that you're not doing
because as long as we believe that we
should be doing something else your
spontaneity is just
um like kept basically it's like no i
can't you're constantly contracted you
can't you know act like this because you
believe that you're supposed to be some
things it's like contracting you
so as soon as you realize oh [ __ ] this
this whole thing is just for the case of
it yeah you you just automatically
embody the spontaneity yeah and um
you you know that you're operating
risk-free you can do
okay within reason whatever you like
it's a party no matter when you were
suffering or you were like
that was a party too man
sorry
your higher self is enjoying
that it's enjoying the ability to suffer
we have such a unique um
let's say gift as human
and um you know on this planet to have
this capacity to feel like [ __ ] we don't
realize that's a really great thing you
know
there are a lot of things that don't
have that ability so even suffering is a
gift even suffering is in this play of
absolute perfection creativity and fun
it just doesn't feel like it but that's
not how it's supposed to feel otherwise
it wouldn't be suffering
so yeah that's just like also the
perspective that's like good to remember
just the capacity to suffer
even that even that
even that has been part of this
innocence because
source if you want to make it something
will not have the capacity to feel
or to suffer or to love
like i said it's like a star almost a
star can't love it just creates and so
it's such a gift that it can create
something with the ability to suffer
that's us
yet when we're suffering we feel so not
special but there's really something
special about that suffering
there's something very unique and very
human and
very rare if you think about on a cosmic
level i wonder how many other beings
that are around that can suffer
especially if you refer to like the
densities
according to the law of one suffering is
definitely only a very small portion of
that
and we just happen to be here at this
point in time where we have this
capacity so even that can be embraced
along the way while you're seeking while
you're suffering it's a gift man yeah
it's a gift and i assure you you're
going to look back when you're like
fully enlightened think wow that that
was actually pretty cool totally to cry
and to feel like that yes yeah because
yeah
andrew houston when he came on our show
he described it as precious fuel and
that stuck with me i love it
yeah depression
yeah
exactly
it is because we just want to get rid of
it right
we just i don't want to feel this right
now
we just somehow lack the perspective of
oh
this is delicious in its own way
it's delicious um deep suffering deep
feeling
if your consciousness progresses you're
no longer going to be able to feel that
you need to enjoy
the journey because you truly do you
kind of become like a robot not that
it's bad it's great
but you look back and you think wow
there was such a flavor to that
suffering that i didn't see at the time
and now i no longer have a self i can't
suffer anymore
but
in hindsight wow that that was pretty
pretty good i can see now why
higher self would
choose to embody or into incarnate is
something that can have that experience
but it's only in hindsight while we're
going through the suffering it's
it's like uh
but
you know maybe it can help someone
if they hear it
next time they're suffering really badly
just think of the flavors of the
suffering you know when when do you feel
this strong
when when are the emotions so nuanced so
consuming
there's something about it although
painful that's just so like you said
it's precious
precious unique
it's really beautiful and no
buddy
ever
will have the same exact
uh
expression of
unique sufferings and unique seekings
and so
to
to
really
enjoy
fully
the uniqueness of
that
thatness
that suchness itself
is
it's so important it's so important
because uh this is it like this is it so
may as well
deeply enjoy um
all of that um that precious fuel that
suffering that seeking that
um realization
that integration
that service
yeah enlightenment is as much
the thing you get to
as it is what happens along the way
and it's completely
literally the outcome does not weigh any
more than the process
i i remember when i was going through
the initial stages of uh no self the
small the death of the character you
could say
i would wake up in the middle of the
night and my head was the size of the
universe and i
i couldn't find where my head started
and where it ended and
even that created immense
disorientation and suffering i i
remember you know like in those movie
scenes where the characters like this
over the bathroom sink like looking in
the mirror and they're like high on some
kind of drug i felt like that i was like
oh my god what what is happening to you
you are
this is this is so scary i i can't find
myself i'm looking at my body but this
isn't me
and i was so scared i was fearful and it
was suffering but in hindsight now
there was something
about it that i will never ever ever get
back yes and
if everyone is going to have that same
kind of experience where something is
frightening or heartbreaking or
when they're out of it they're gonna
they'll look back and think wow there
was depth there that i've never felt
again the uniqueness of that experience
was the flavors that made it could never
come together again now
they could never make that particular
feeling that particularly like dread and
existentialism and i didn't know where
my body started and stopped i didn't
know who i was and this is the dead of
night and i felt like i was tripping
and i was so scared but guided by this
grace
guided by this beautiful sense of
everything's going to be fine you are
[ __ ] off for now but you're gonna be
okay
but at the time it's like oh i just want
this to be over
but that should be wished less you know
suffering should be embodied more a
little
it shouldn't be resisted along the way
because like you said everyone has this
unique formulation unique mind
even if i tune into the mind of another
it's nothing like mine everything in my
paradigm gets shifted it's like it's
rearranging if you tune into the
energies of someone else
and i thought people were reasonably the
same i thought we all kind of have the
same kind of patterns in our minds and
same templates and stuff but it's not
true we're all formulated completely
differently and we all have completely
unique experiences of suffering and
completely unique experiences of just
happiness and love and
the diversity the diversity
love how you
all powered by grace also that was so
beautiful
and i love how you talked about the
synthesis of flavors coming together for
the exact feeling
um and i feel like on our next
conversations that we can explore this
like
so much deeper this is such a cool heart
to it
um yeah
i love even just tuning into that love
feels different across all
eight billion in this collective
um that
all the patterns of expression feel
different for all eight billion and
that's that's such a beautiful thing too
um
and yet it's all like comprehended
um
by the same
one
and that's also so beautiful at the same
time
and so
and there's and there's just no ground
um to stick on and then that's so
freeing and so liberating
we covered and just so much goodness
colette i'm
so grateful it's great
yeah me too it was really it's a very
good sharing especially after being
quiet for so long it was like i don't
know what i'm gonna say and uh
i hope that i i can say something and we
did we did and i'm very very grateful
and um very happy to have spoken with
you
it's kind of like just been
like a city i've been marinating kind of
and not i haven't really allowed an
outlet because there's there's like here
there's this want to like make sure that
everything is stable first that i don't
conceptualize something in a way that
it's not
and these past six months i'm probably
going to be back on instagram after you
post this
um but the past six months have just
allowed us to like really settle
and also for the teaching to be able to
come forth in a way that
is more understood
and more holistic and yeah i really
appreciate being able to speak here
and thank you for giving me the
opportunity to do that and it's been
such a great sharing i really loved
every minute
and
yeah in our next ones we can definitely
elaborate on some of the stuff we've
said
very exciting
thanks for your beautiful radiance love
thank you likewise
i feel so good
thank you so cool
yeah
[Music]
cool
cool cool
so
um let's see what shall we
say now we can say
um
thanks everyone for tuning in thank you
guys
um
we would love to hear from you in the
comments below if you want to write a
comment we'd love to hear from you
um anything that really like stood out
caught your attention helped you on your
journey
where you're at in your journey
maybe either colette or i can come in
and write back to you
[Music]
also
you can subscribe to the channel if you
haven't yet
um you can also
like the video that helps the algorithm
and even share the video also that's a
good idea
if it brought you value you can share it
with others
and just spread the message more
you can find um colette's instagram in
the bio so you can go and check out her
instagram where she also makes lots of
posts about the subject
and you can go and follow her there is
there another good link that we should
put in the bio
not yet but very soon possibly this
month i think yes mystery
i love it
yeah yeah we got to expand the teaching
so yeah i'll be back on instagram this
month feb and
shortly after
some more links
cool
so then check out the bio um
for those links also we'll add them
there as they get published
and also the link to um no limits
society the organization that we were
talking about training free agents for
the ignition of global awakening
manifesting shambhala
if you want to check that out the links
in the bio as well
and
yeah i'm really excited we'll probably
um tune back into
uh
doing another one of these rounds soon
and just see how that keeps blossoming
in our friendship super looking forward
to it i'll
i'll go ahead and i'll end on the
recording and then you and i can just
stay in the room for a little bit okay
okay bye everyone
we love you
i thank you we love you